what is the data on covert 19 telling us
right now well let's start with
the big picture this is showing you
cases across the uk and you can probably
see look very big
uh spike around the winter and then
coming down to really quite low levels
uh at the moment but i want to focus
specifically on variants and
in this case the growth profile of
variance so these lines showing you how
fast they grew from the moment where
they passed
10 cases just so we can compare the the
shape of these lines
there's the kent variant up very quickly
uh indeed that was of course around
uh december and then you've got this the
indian variant six uh beat 1.617.2
and just look i'll zoom in and you can
probably see that it's up
actually even faster than the kemp
variant was at this comparable
point up to just under 7000 cases
as of a few days ago now that matters
because of course there's a lot of talk
recently what with the dominant comings
uh testimony about whether we didn't
move fast enough when it came to the
kemp variant so let's just look at some
of those
that timeline for the kent variant uh
what we knew when
on the 19th of december the prime
minister that's when he gave his press
conference
uh about the variant cancelling
christmas uh in a sense
and then it was on the 6th of january
that england went into
its third lockdown and by that stage
look at that line by that stage you're
up to 22
500 cases so very advanced a lot of
cases
and if i bring on the indian variant
again you can see we are much earlier
than we were any of those points so some
people are asking whether we need to
act earlier as well to try and prevent
the same thing happening all over again
but here's the flip side okay have a
look at this we'll go back to that first
chart
at the start showing you the big picture
of cases around the uk now i'm going to
add on
uh the kent variant uh and indeed the
indian variant and bear in mind these
are on different axes those
black lines aren't going up quite as
much as the white lines
but just to show you when this was
happening and how fast they were growing
and there's something you've probably
spotted already look when the kent
variant was growing
cases were very high very high across
the uk whereas right now
with the indian variant it's certainly
growing but cases across the uk
are much much lower that really matters
and it's that balancing act between
those two things do we act earlier
or do we bear in mind that the situation
is quite different this time around
that's what's going to be occupying the
minds of public health officials in the
coming weeks